yo Dre quoi de neuf, j'ai quelque chose à dire que
vous écoutez deux confiance Ice Cube
eazy-e et dr.  Dre, ils veulent NWA
, tuons-le de manière gommeuse, nous étions
ensemble depuis peut-être quatre bonnes années,
puis nous avons été séparés pour le reste, alors
juste pour comprendre comment ramener tous
ces gens et vous savez que la facilité
n'était pas là alors nous  a dû faire face à
son Tameka nerveux pour obtenir les droits de
la musique et vous savez juste que nous avions besoin d'
au moins vingt-neuf millions de dollars et
que beaucoup d'entreprises voulaient dépenser
tellement moins que nous ne pouvions pas faire le
film correctement alors  il a juste fallu tant d'
années pour tout rassembler quel
argent mais pourquoi tu dois être si impitoyable
parce que tu penses que tu vas j'essaie juste
de rentrer à la maison pour revenir dans ce
costume ma mère est comme ça 50 $ André
tourne des seaux  ne paie pas sous les
factures ici c'est un début savez-vous
que la chance changerait la situation le
prendriez-vous
juste le premier serait difficile de perdre dans
la rue mon sixième oh hé j'étais dope
c'est difficile de mettre dix ans en deux
heures  donc vous devez comprendre ce qui
doit être dans le film donc o  tout
ça était que si ça n'avait rien à
voir avec le groupe NWA alors c'est une
histoire personnelle et ça n'a probablement pas
besoin d'être dans le film
il y avait des choses que nous devions changer
à la volée et nous devions juste  être si
vif à la volée, il y avait la
chose qui n'a été construite qu'à partir de la
Fraternité dans la camaraderie que nous avions
en fait vous savez que nous avons enduré toutes
ces choses ensemble mon
DJ au cœur de coriandre à la menthe vous savez que che avait deux
ans de choses à faire  traverser, j'ai dû
aimer changer mon accent et apprendre à
faire tout ce genre de choses à propos d'
eazy-e, alors quand nous avons vraiment commencé à frapper
la cible et que nous nous sommes mis dans un rythme et que nous avons
commencé à être fiers les uns des autres
sous le jour il  nous a juste vraiment aidés
mais c'était très très très difficile très
difficile Je suis dans une position unique vous
savez ce que nous sommes quand votre premier film
fait cent millions d'états vous savez
vous êtes vraiment vraiment dans une position votre
stock est très élevé donc c'est  tout
pour m'assurer que mon prochain ro  le est quelque chose
du même calibre et quand vous commencez
avec deux comme ça, vous savez qu'ils vous regardent
différemment, donc je
choisis définitivement le bon scénario, le
bon réalisateur et je m'assure simplement que
les dominos tombent en place, soyez
honnête avec  toi je ne connais
rien au hip-hop mais je sais que tu es
spécial vous les gars censés être quelqu'un que
vous pouvez j'ai attrapé mes clients à cause de
ce à quoi ils ressemblent votre chanson
yeux de slammer gangs et drogues notre art est le
reflet de  notre réalité
parle un peu de vérité et les gens perdent
leurs mères
ce ne sont pas les Crips et les sangs c'est
une menace du gouvernement fédéral w
watch on continue mec on peut prendre le contrôle de
la [ __ ] de route
comment tu vas de vendre des pierres dans la
maison de dope  dîner dans une maison blanche